this morning German police are searching
for what's being called a priceless set
of stolen jewels surveillance video
shows thieves breaking into the 500 year
old royal castle of Dresden Monday
Roxana Saberi reports on how the
burglars pulled it off these jewels
glittering with diamonds rubies and
sapphires vanished within minutes when
two hooded thieves seen in the security
camera footage used an axe to smash
through a glass showcase by the time the
police arrived the burglars had fled
possibly in this car found torched and
left behind the drama unfolded inside
Dresden's 18th century green vault the
museum holds one of Europe's largest
collections of treasures such
identifiable stolen artifacts would be
impossible to sell on the open market
says Arthur brand a prominent art theft
investigator odd can be money but you
cannot sell it once it's in the criminal
underworld
it stays there authorities now fear the
thieves will break up the jewelry or
melt it down but there is a silver
lining the museum's most precious
treasure a rare 41 karat green diamond
is sitting safely in New York on loan to
the Metropolitan Museum of Art for CBS
this morning Roxana Saberi
London